well so what's interesting about the
lenses that we're creating is that their
seat mount lenses so you know can DSLRs
they use EF mounts nikon sees nikon
mounts every many cameras have different
amounts that they use for their lenses
and since ours will be seamount you need
a seamount camera or you would need like
an adapter to use them so actually I
think that the cameras that they would
be most compatible with would be the
actual Bolex cameras from back in the
day so sea mount is actually sorry see
mount is actually the most popular mount
in the world there are more c-mount
lenses than any other lenses and that
has to do with the fact that they're
used on security cameras and most
microscopes for instance or basically a
fancy sea mount that you can attach a
seamount camera to most telescopes or
halves email update on film
right are our seamount oriented so so
that it will exist in that world but
they're really intended for use with our
camera I think the gh2 gh3 cameras by
Panasonic health there's a way you see
mount with those cameras right they are
but i think that people use DNA with
what there's an adapter visa yet you
know but really they're intended for use
with our camera there's a few things
that are unique about them that make
them work with our camera that make them
not ideal to use of other cameras and
the market is really to create the idea
is really to create a system that works
together really well from camera and
lenses and accessories it was like that
so that
you're getting a full experience when
you come to digital access it close to
coming to buy a body from these guys and
lends us from those guys and kind of mix
and match and figure it out you know
these are met to be married together
yeah they are fixed focus fixed aperture
lenses which is it's a little unusual
but that's also something that we felt
you know you could buy set of lenses and
you would have the option to create
different coverage shots more
inexpensively
average consumer lens right now is
pretty expensive generates to have a
decent lens you're looking at you know
500 to 25 hundred dollars and that is
really expensive for most people so we
wanted to create something that would be
very low in cost that you could buy a
whole bunch of them to cover the range
of different
you would need and that's also something
that would a lot of people who are not
teksavvy as far as lenses
they can buy oh this is the lens that
works indoors and lets you shoot you
know a close-up from four feet away it's
like very user-friendly I guess type of
lenses so they're definitely not going
to be for everybody but I you know we
think that this is a good type of lens
that isn't available now that people
will definitely find uses for and will
fit well on the turret mount so you can
put three of these little because
they're all prime lenses you can put all
three of them on there switch to the
close-up
create a very strong images that are
very specific image
most lenses have a sweet spot you know
and focus distance that is where the
lens performs the best and so instead of
you know trying to let people were using
the lens find those sweet spots for
themselves we're just making a lens that
only has the sweet spot so it will
always be performing at what its best
with me
the problem of lenses is that because
we're a one-to-one pixel sensor that's a
very sharp and very low noise we need a
very high resolution lenses to really
maximize the sensor and the camera so
most of the cameras that have bigger
sensors they use either pixel binning or
lime skipping or some other way to get
their large number of pixels down to a
smaller number of pencils and because of
that their lines per millimeter
resolution of the lenses that are
appropriate for those is you know
sometimes in the 25 to 30 range for
lenses that are 500 to 1,500 dollars but
we realized that for ours we needed it
to be about 40 so instead of 25 to 30 we
need like 40 to 45 lines per millimeter
of resolution and this is just not
offered by lenses under three thousand
dollars so we were saying how can we
make a 40 to 45 line per millimeter some
super sharp lens with low distortion for
under 300 bucks that was our goal and
and we sat down with
lens designer and kish who is famous for
making optics for directors viewfinders
and other kinds of things like that
which are actually very challenging
because in a director's viewfinder
you're essentially making a lens system
that can simulate every other ones on
the planet and all the other formats so
with this challenge as L said we decided
to make the lenses that were fixed
focused and fixed aperture and this
means that normally when you design a
lens you because I also talked about you
have a sweet spot and then you make a
whole bunch of compromises in your legs
design in order to make it focus at two
feet and infinity and change f-stop and
all that kind of thing you make a whole
series of compromises so we decided
instead of making any compromises at all
we were going to make completely
uncompromising lenses that have amazing
clarity low distortion and really high
resolution for cheap price and this is
television
tradeoff is just that they're not
adjustable so you have to adjust your
shots to the lens
adjusting the lens a shot but the
performance and the images you get from
it will be yeah more than 10 times the
value of what you pay
you